tel le plus long vol sans escale de
l'histoire atterri ce matin on vient
d'écrire caroline un paragraphe de
l'histoire de l'aviation civile en fin
de semaine alors le plus long vol au
monde sans escale a commencé vendredi
soit à l'aéroport donc john f kennedy à
new york vendredi donc à 21h27
précisément l'appareil qui a décollé
comme ça pour un long périple elle l'a
mené jusqu'à signer où il a atterri
dimanche matin à 7h42 après imaginer
19h05 de vol c'est une prouesse signé
par la compagnie qantas airways donc
elle a fait ça avec cet appareil c'est
le boeing 787 9 un appareil là qui a été
mis en service en 2014 par boeing c'est
un appareil qui permet vraiment de faire
des très très long courrier donc vol
expérimental dit on du côté de cointe
ans avec ce boeing
on a fait seize mille kilomètres on a
poussé vraiment les capacités de cet
appareil
au départ il pesait 2 133 tonnes au
décollage dont 100 une tonne en kérosène
seulement comme on est arrivé là a
diminué en fait le poids c'est en
minimisant le nombre de passagers était
seulement 49 vous dire c'est un appareil
qui peut compter en 250 et 300 passagers
en fait précisément 290 passagers alors
49 passagers principalement ses des
employés de quintos et quatre pilotes
dont qui se sont relayés comme ça pour
être capable d'amener la pareille à bon
port pendant ses 19 heures de vol mais à
l'intérieur de l'appareil avait
également des chercheurs des chercheurs
de deux universités australiennes qui
était à bord ou pour observer la façon
dont les passagers ont dormi se sont
alimentés pendant toutes ces heures que
c'est presque une journée entière dans
l'appareil est également surveillé leur
niveau de mélatonine
vous savez de l'hormone du sommeil alors
on verra si qantas en frais de liaison
commerciale parce que pour le moment
c'est expérimental
regardez du plus long vol à travers le
monde pour le moment le plus long trajet
aérien commercial au monde est
actuellement une liaison entre new york
et singapour ssa a été lancée en 2018
par singapore airlines ça dure dix
2h30 c'est suivi de los angeles
singapour avec un vol de 17 heures 55
minutes et puis san francisco singapour
avec un vol un petit peu moins long le
17h35 les vols les plus longs canada à
petit aperçu comme ça c'est toronto
manille donc qui nous amène un vol de 16
heures 25 minutes et puis si vous partez
de vancouver peut vous rendre à
melbourne en 16h20 à l'heure des vols de
plus en plus long reste à voir si la
demande sera au rendez vous si les
passagers n'ont pas trop peur donc
d'embarquer dans un avion comme ça pour
que de 19 heures de vol quand même merci
michel